tom allen goes wild with those stunts
and please understand he's not as
invincible as the spidey counterpart for
those dangerous scenes in uncharted want
to know more let's look at some of the
most dangerous stunts that tom endured
for our enjoyment of course
number one this scene was just too
complex for us to take on in one segment
so we'll just go ahead and start off
with those crates of course they
wouldn't have a world famous actor jump
out of a plane so vfx coordinators
utilized a robotic arm and some blue
screen to really place him in the safest
harm they could our motto is that things
should look dangerous while being safe
that's not always the case the final
look certainly fooled us and have no
fear because even the crates were fake
yes that's right it looks to us they
opted for a softer material than wood
and good thing too because jumping onto
a wooden crate screams splinters to us
number two part two of tom's most
dangerous stunt is actually the start of
it it all begins with an unsecured car
ramming nathan drake off a plane this
time it pretty much felt like tom was
actually getting hit by one for real it
didn't take just one time to get the
scene right it took a whopping 17 takes
over a series of weeks to finally sell
the hit poor tom really had a workout
with this one so my parents were always
like why are you so tired all the time
but wait it gets worse holland's own
mother was unlucky enough to visit the
set and witness her boy amidst the chaos
we can only imagine how many times she
screamed at tom to look both ways
number three there are worse things than
being hit by a blue car how about being
injured during a sword fight fortunately
not the sword accident you were thinking
about but tom did get some pretty bad
tendonitis while swordfighting alongside
mark wahlberg he assures everyone that
any swordplay is not in his future
saying he will never do it again and
even worse he had to jump on a flight
while recovering to film spiderman no
way home seriously his break from acting
couldn't have come sooner he needs an
ice bath
number four tom took a nasty fall on
some rooftop tiles during a pretty
chaotic rooftop scene who knew falling
on a bunch of hard roof tiles could do
so much damage and the damage to his
body was pretty severe describing his
injured hips being black and blue after
the incident but like all of his stunts
gone wrong tom always walked away with
his body and mind intact saying i walked
away from every stunt but i definitely
limped from a few
number five how does one convincingly
skydive in front of a blue screen well
it takes a whole lot of wires they
hooked tom up with a ton of them
spinning him around in every direction
they even subjected him to hanging
upside down and flailing about good
thing he's used to this kind of thing
because this would have made us sick
within the first two seconds
number six one word for this one ouch
holland's evie's stunt work wasn't
always protected by harnesses as it is
apparent in this painful looking scene
instead of using a stunt double he just
really wanted to be slammed in the side
of a table we guess our question is how
do you just walk away from that one
number seven tom holland doesn't have a
huge fancy for wires and harnesses and
that chandelier leap really needed a
whole lot of them he really trusted
those stunt coordinators to keep those
strings strong and luckily he walked
away unscathed but even with all those
strings if just one of them broke things
could have ended badly for our spidey
actor
number eight an a-lister's teeth are
kind of their forte so any risk to those
shiny chompers has got to go holland
always had to wear a ring around his
neck and this ring kept bouncing up and
hitting his teeth but as he expressed
his concerns to the prop master they
were able to make a simple fix with a
rubber alternative
number nine like we've hinted at
throughout this video tom really doesn't
like wires it seems like he got injured
more often than not on them doing all
those high kicks probably did a number
on his hamstrings we guess he'll be
taking a long hard look at future roles
because the way he describes it they did
more harm than good
number 10 holland went from amateur to
stunt professional in a very short
amount of time all of the training he
had received prior to uncharted really
made the preparation for the film more
you could say
simple his peter tingle really came in
handy and worked well with mark although
tom reportedly worked hard to impress
his co-star little did he know that
wahlberg was just acting old to get away
from the heavy stunts i'm already
working on my old voice we're so glad to
see tom holland make it out of this one
intact not to say he may be angry with
himself a few years down the road but
knowing he did this for his own
satisfaction it seems like everything
worked out just fine in the end do you
think we'll see tom get a little more
dangerous with his stunts in the future
let us know in the comments and thanks
for watching the things